hello everyone and welcome to the finals
of the 2020 chasuble Masters it's again
Magnus Carlsen versus onigiri and after
game two did Magnus won Game three was a
draw so here this is Game four of the
match and Giri is in a must-win
situation he must win on demand with
black which is not easy especially
against the player like Magnus but it is
what he needs to do to stay alive in
this match so without further ado let's
check it out and I would just like to
congratulate the winners of yesterday's
arena's so let me just check check that
out so the winners are the modest guy I
think in gazzarri and India's are of
those are the winners of the top three
places
followed by Travis numata Eric Nam
incredible one two three and Aiko wanted
101 we will all die in shock and those
are the winners of the other matters
Friday arena and the winners of meadow
arena art hand sanitizer team agate and
deja slaw followed by Bach Robert PL
smugly so one two seven
Hakan nine and nine six six decline four
four four four one rx meadow means fear
underscore Brazil and meadow 1700 so
congratulations everyone and hope to see
you all back next Friday now getting
back to this game and it is it is a very
interesting one we now go into it so
Magnus with the white pieces opens with
E 4 and Giri replies with C 5 when you
when you need a win then you you go for
the Sicilian night of 3 we've d6 and
Bishop to b5 check Magnus goes for the
canal attack we have Knight to d7
blocking and now a 4 a 4 very useful as
it well slows down blacks development
and the Queen side also in the future
can go a 5 a 6 but also if black tries
to kick away your Bishop you don't allow
b5 for one of the reasons so adjust
Knight f6 is going after the pawn and
Knight to c3 defending with g6 from Giri
and a5 now we have Bishop g7 Giri
prepares to Castle and now well you can
go a six and try and play again like
that it has been tried we have just
castles from Magnus and now gear it
keeps the
back with a six we have the ship back to
e2 and now gearing castles and rook to
e1 now that when the bishop moves the
rook will nicely be also helping out
with the defense of the pawn and also
you might have some a 5 on the IDS in
the future if this night ever moves from
b7 and here there is a game in the
database for Knight the b8 who was
played from the from the Russian team
championship I don't remember I don't
know who played I think maybe Valentina
Guney and I had white our teammate had
the black pieces but ok but here we have
b5 and it is now a new move so already
as of mu9 we have a completely new game
and now Magnus of course he doesn't want
to allow this structure to remain and
face before so he captures on b6 ALPA
song so we have Bishop to b7 there's
always time to recapture so there's no
rush it is attacked twice so it's not a
problem
d3 defending d4 pawn and only now Geary
captures but now the knight no longer
guards d e4 e5 square and Magnus takes
this opportunity to strike in the center
with E 5 we have Knight F to d5 by
gearing now the night on b6 shows up
useful as as the defender of this night
magnus trades once captures captures and
now he captures and v6 with ich a person
d6 + c3 now numbing the the power of
this dark square bishop and now usually
this will be a weak bone however black
really controlled this well and we
didn't have the open Sicilian where
white broke in the center would be 4 so
this bone will not really be all that
weak
stop rook to e8 by Geary and now Bishop
to b2 we have Queen to b6 putting
pressure on the b2 pawn and the Queen to
c2 now by Magnus and a5 we have h3 from
Magnus and the bishop to c6 now add the
bishop will be more useful there maybe
it will help out with the support of a 4
you can switch switch places Queen b7
disappear you can have a nice battery
here so I only know a very useful move
Magnus goes d4 he strikes in the center
we have C captures Knight captures now
attacking the bishop here but now a very
nice trick from Geary night the b4 now
putting pressure on the Queen and of
course if this is captured then
you capture on d4 and this is exactly
what Magnus goes for we have C caps or
some B for Bishop captures on d4 and now
just goes for B captors in 85 and here
Magnus created a very strong passport
while allowing the cat for an F do so
Giri goes for it Bishop captures on f2
and now as the king is in check King to
f1 and now okay you don't have time to
capture the roof right away because the
Queen is hanging but now Queen to d4 and
there is still the issue of what to do
with the rook now what you should do
here is actually Queen to c3 giving up
the exchange here is definitely the way
to go
for example after Queen captures Bishop
captures you give up the exchange and
after this is captured you still have
your passport on a5 which is incredibly
strong and you still have the bishop
pair so that's well worth the the
exchange
however Magnus went for Queen captures
on c6 he said okay you capture my room
but I'm gonna take two of your pieces
however there's a problem here now feel
free to pause the video and figure out
the problem while I give you a couple of
seconds so for those of you who were
able to do it congratulations on
spotting the obvious move and for those
of you who just want to enjoy the show
it's Bishop capture sunny one
yes it's usually not the most obvious
move but here it is and it is because
there's a problem with recapturing the
bishop for example if rookery captures
then you lose the bishop here and now
it's two rooks against the rook and
Bishop and the white will white will
really struggle here there's already an
attack here on this pawn this is a weak
pawn and the white king is wide open and
f1 another thing if King captures the
kind of guard the bishop then queen g1
is checkmate since the bishop cannot
defend the the rook just pins the bishop
so Magnus did the only thing he could he
played Bishop character sunny one now
there is no capture which of course
makes sense there is no checkmate
but Gary finds the beauty queen capture
son b2 and now this comes with a double
attack on the rook end on the bishop
here and you don't have all that much to
do and the Magnus was was a well he was
very
Costard here here we even have a short
clip of how discussed that he was so
let's just enjoy that for a second this
is what happened after you replay the
Queen captures on b2 so let's just check
it out
there's Queen captures and b2 played now
he ponders on that
now there's the surprise and there's the
disgust yes it's there it is very nice
and now of course in the end a little
bit of laughing as he knows he now has
to that the game is lost and he has to
go into blitz tiebreaks
so here Magnus just played Bishop to f3
and also in this position he resigned
the game as there is nothing more to be
done here even if you I don't think this
was an actual move I think he just
picked up the bishop maybe sawed it all
so everything was hanging and then he
just you know dropped it and clicked
resigned he didn't
the Bishop every move doesn't it doesn't
make any sense but even if he tried to
like save the rook like say Queen c3 or
moving the rook you have to allow this
capture and after King g1 it's still
very very much unplayable for white so
incredible incredible find by yury he
wins the game with black on demand and
he equalizes the match in game 4 so
incredible development and now they go
into blitz tiebreaks which we are also
going to cover after this video so
that's the game I do hope you enjoyed it
I would like to thank Allah Raja
Donald Brady quant rangaiah Hamid
mizuage and leucine the last Lester for
contribution to my channel thank you I
really appreciate it as usual you can
check - on my previous videos Aaron
think all for watching and I will see
you soon continuing the coverage of the
chest bull masters 2020 checking up on
your wonderful suggestions and whatever
else happens in the chess world so thank
you all I will see you soon and have an
excellent rest of your day and if you
haven't seen the new video by Agatha
Torino - check it out the link will be
the first thing in the description below
see you soon